lee wants to know if you like him
flynn's brother
netflix apparently runs in the family at
least for these stars
landing a job on a hit series or movie
is a major deal for the average person
but for some star-studded families it's
basically a yearly occurrence
you'll never guess who's related from
shows like bridgerton
and jenny and georgia one of your
brothers played thor he was thor
yes bessie carter had made her big
netflix original debut as prudence
featherington
in one of the platform's biggest hits
ridgeton
we all love to hate prudence but you
can't deny her polished acting skills
when you find out who her mom is you'll
know why acting seems to come so easily
to her
her mom is imelda staunton also known as
queen elizabeth on netflix other hit
series
the crown anyone else as shook as us to
find out that professor
umbridge had had a daughter all these
years but imelda is nothing like her
on-screen characters and has said that
she's fortunate her daughter was born
into the business
instead of being thrown blindly into the
theater and industry like she was
nothing but support from these two stars
i like it when it's just downstairs and
opposition it's all the family and the
and the staff who were there if you
weren't obsessed with joey king
and the kissing booth do you even watch
netflix
all jokes aside joey king made major
waves on the streaming platform with her
teen romcom magic
but there's another actress in the king
family who's also made her first netflix
splash
her sister hunter king has worked in
series like life and pieces but recently
appeared on the netflix series nailed it
alongside joey bet you can't name a more
iconic sister duo
we didn't take a long time to film
scenes if you couldn't tell we're very
professional
we can all admit catherine langford made
us cry
multiple times with her performance as
hannah baker in 13 reasons why
and then not long after showed us how
iconic she could be
in her netflix original cursed well if
you've run out of catherine content
you can always venture to her netflix
star sister josephine langford
josephine got a pretty big break
starring in the y franchise after
but she became a netflix star when she
took on the role of emma
in their movie moxie look at them
they're basically identical
i don't want to sound arrogant but i
feel like we both know what we're doing
so we don't really call each other up
and be like
phoebe denover wasn't a familiar face to
us when she made her appearance as
daphne on netflix bridgeton
but while she was new to netflix she was
in no way new to the world of television
that's because her mom sally denover has
spent over 30 years working in the
industry
as sally webster on the uk series
coronation street
she may not be on a netflix original but
that's pretty impressive
sally is nothing but proud of her
daughter they even watched bridgerton as
a family
except for the more intimate scenes but
they've grown up with it so it's kind of
part of their life
ginny and georgia is all about the
importance of family and no one gets
that better than the actors who play
joey and padma on the series
their names are raymond and rebecca a
black and their
brother and sister we couldn't believe
it either the two never really have any
on-screen time together
and maybe that's why we never realized
how alike they look
did you catch the resemblance between
the two characters if you caught netflix
movie the dig
you would have seen ray finds also known
as lord voldemort himself
in action as basil brown however wraith
isn't the only one who's made it big in
his family
he isn't related to any netflix original
stars but his nephew
hero finds tiffen is one of the stars in
the after franchise
yup hardin scott is related to voldemort
rafe also has a brother joseph who plays
fred waterford in the handmaid's tale
a long time ago he played for the bbc
lawrence for rabia and i played his
brother way back in the background
robin was probably one of the greatest
additions to the stranger things cast
and a lot of it has to do with how cool
her actress maya hawk
is being cool apparently runs in her
family
because both her parents are in
hollywood ethan hawk
and uma thurman not only that but just
like her daughter uma thurman is a
netflix star
you can watch her in the series chambers
as nancy
ethan hawk has said he loves getting to
watch maya do her
thing and express we couldn't agree more
it all just kind of fell into place and
they were glad to have her and i was
glad to have her and she was happy to be
there
dudley dursley has come a long way from
his days on privet drive
and tormenting his cousin his actor
harry melling worked as harry beltik
in the game-changing series the queen's
gambit ironically
harry has a cousin sam trotin who shares
the same netflix fame as him
sam stars in two netflix originals the
ritual
as dom and mank as john they must have
some pretty epic family reunions
what does it matter to them you may know
amy poehler best from her years on parks
and recreation
but netflix has scooped her up for
originals like moxie and wine country
but amy apparently wasn't doing any
netflix films without her brother greg
poehler
because he also has a role in both films
greg played dr dickswing in wine country
and the news anchor in moxie it seems
like they're pretty close
especially considering they wrote a
sitcom called welcome to sweden together
well i saw my sister making tv shows
over the past 30 40 years julie and the
phantoms is arguably one of the most
adorable shows on netflix and booboo
stewart as willie just makes it all the
better
does anyone remember when he was just a
team playing seth in twilight
well his younger sister fieval stewart
followed right in his footsteps
she landed her first netflix gig as izzy
on atypical
and is thriving the two are super close
and even did videos together for disney
and there was an open house so we danced
big time that vibe the club for the
older kids
if you've seen house of cards you know
just how awesome the cast of the netflix
series is
including kate mara who plays zoe barnes
in the series
but those good acting genes were also
passed on to her sister
rooney mara who made her netflix debut
in the movie the discovery
being actors have brought the sisters
closer than ever
kate said bonding over their audition
experiences was
super special that you can actually bond
with
a sibling over i mean that's very rare
holly date star emma roberts has been in
showbiz
since before she even knew she wanted to
be an actress
she spent her childhood roaming filming
trailers and movie sets
all because her aunt is pretty woman
star julia roberts
imagine playing dress-up on a movie set
like emma did
goals julia roberts may not have a
netflix original but you can still catch
her in movies like wonder and stepmom
i remember i was on erin brockovich that
set a lot
and and you remember all her costumes in
that movie alexandra d'addario got her
big break when she starred as annabeth
in the percy jackson and the olympians
films
but she became a netflix star when she
landed a role in the movie
when we first met as avery her brother
is matthew daddario
no big deal he just starred in the huge
television series
shadowhunters as alec yeah yeah that
sounds great
chris hemsworth or thor god of thunder
made an impression on netflix with their
original movie extraction
now we all know he's brothers with
hunger games star liam hemsworth
but people tend to forget that there's a
third brother who just happens to also
be a netflix star
luke hemsworth he's the oldest of the
three and stars in the netflix film
death of me
it's not only the acting gene that's
strong in the hemsworth family right
we'd wake up in the morning and we'd
literally say see your mum and just
disappear into the bush melissa mccarthy
is one of the funniest actors on netflix
have you seen her netflix movie thunder
force not to mention other comedies
she's been in like identity thief
but if it wasn't for her cousin jenny
mccarthy melissa wouldn't have landed
her very first acting job
jenny mccarthy is also a comedian and
actress and works in movies like scary
movie 3
and is now one of the judges on the
masked singer not a netflix star
but still pretty impressive thinking
about how interconnected the world of
netflix is
is bizarre and our heads are still
spinning from finding out professor
umbridge's daughter
is an actress in bridgerton what
relative reveal was the most surprising
to you